e
herkese merhaba Hepiniz hoş geldiniz
Öncelikle doğduğumuz andan itibaren
bugüne gelene dek daima küçük sana neyi
ve değer vermeyi hayatımıza Uyandırdık
ve kullanımı yaşadık aracımızı Ama bugün
bundan farklı olarak hep birlikte pis
ediyoruz İlk başta biraz böyle Nasıl
yani ne işim Siz bir ifade oluşabilir
çok da ama biraz kişisel ve farklı
açılardan bakacağız hep birlikte önce
biraz kendimden bahsetmek istiyorum ben
yazık göster 28 yaşındayım asla
Samsun'dayım bugün burada olduğu için
kırılmaz mutluyum Allah bu
ve Azra'nın hiç haber şimdi hangisiydi
mühendis olarak çalışırken 30 kilo
verdim bir süre sormuştum ve 30 Kilo
verirken açmış olduğumuz dön sayfam
vardı Ve bu herkes olur Birlikte
yürüttüğü boyunda yaşamsal ham
Mühendislik serüvenin son bulmasıyla
tamamen bir iş hayaldi Instagram sayfama
ilk açtığında Aslında bunun Sırrı diye
bir terim ile yok yani uzun sır ne demek
kimse bundan bir haber Ben bile bundan
bir haberdir ama 30 kilo vermeye
başlayan birisi olarak bir şeyler
Çekip bir şeyler paylaşıp Aslında
kendimi buna motive ediyorum salata
tarifleri yorum paylaşıyorum ve
organları birçok insanın takip ediyor
onlar motive oluyor böyle başlayan her
yer değiştirirler bu yolda Şimdi impuls
Sıramı ve kendi kurmuş olduğum bir marka
var bu şekilde hayatına devam ediyorum
Bugünde dalacağım şeyler de hem kendi
hayatım o çocukları arayacağım hem de
aslında kendinde yüzleştiğim duyguları
zarar vermeye çalışacağım Öncelikle
Bir Hayal kurulurken yani atıyorum ben
bunu almamız dan b noktasına giderken
şeklinde bir şeyleri ifade etmeye
çalıştığımız bir hayali kurarken bu
hayali küçümseme mememiz gerekiyor Yani
para mı düşünmemiz gerekiyor Heyecanımı
Bir Hayal kurarken bu hayali yüzümüzde
büyük etmemiz gerekiyor Yani bir
hayaliniz varsa bu sizin gözünüzde ne
kadar büyürse asla o hayale ulaşmak için
de
harcadığınız çaba gözünüzde diyecek Yani
bir yola çıkmadan o yolda sizin neler
neler sizi nelerin beklediğini
düşünseniz Aslında o yol gittikçe
uzayacak ve hayalimize ulaşmak gittikçe
de zorlaşacak o yüzden bugün kuracağımız
hayallere ip istemez istiyorum yani
kuracağım sayarlar Aslında
ulaşılamayacak şeyler değil aslında
herkesin yapabileceği şeyler burada
hayatında bu Herkesin davranmak
istiyorum ben azla ve çalışırken çok
başarılı mühendisliğin buna ben de
çalışıyorum Yurtdışından yeni gelmişim
çok başarılı bir sürü insan aslında
Normalde Sonrasında da ama artık bir şey
yapmak istiyorum Bir yazılım şirketine
geçmek istiyorum yazılım şirketine geçti
ve aynı maaşla bir adım şirkette
çalışmaya başladım
Sonra uyudum şirketinde çalışırken
yazılım altın tam olarak yapacağımı
anladım ve yazılım şirketinden bu
Instagram'da yazılım şirketi Biliyorsun
çok zor bir hale gelmeye başlamıştı
sonrasında bu işten kovulduk ve
İstanbul'daki hayatım biraz da sona erdi
geriye sadece benim elimde bir Instagram
sayfası kaldı Ve ben gerçekten bu
Instagram sayfasına ne yapacağımı
bilmiyorum il hayalim var hayalim
gerçekten nereye giderseniz de çok
Büyümek ve çok büyük bir hedef kitleye
gerçekten bu yavruları güzel motivasyon
ve güzel çeliklerle onlara hayatın
Gerçekten yaşanabilecek güzel şey
olduğunu göstermek istiyorum İnsanları
mutlu etmek istiyorum insanların sabah
uyandığında ilk gördüğü insan olmak
istiyorum Belki belki kahve içerken
belki yemekte Belki de kurduğum hayal de
yürürken yani her anında bir insan
olacak olmak istiyorum kurduğum hayatı
çok büyük bir kitle çok büyük bir
motivasyon sağlamak diyebilirim bu hayal
kurduğunda ilk karşılaştığım zorlukla
uçtan kovmak oldu aslında bu kovulmak
hayatın bana sunduğu negatif bir şey
yani Benim de olmayan ve belli zorlu bir
yanlış yola sapan bir eskiydi sonrasında
Ben İstanbul'a yeni taşındım Havva
yaşındayım yine bir hayatın manasını da
zorlu bir koşulu olan babamla sohbetin
var diyor bu bayağı etkiler sürekli bir
tanesini benim için Neyse ben kovulmuş
tanesi bu geri döndüm işte Ekmek
yapıyorum bazı sosyal medyaları
yönetiyorum gerçekten yani varacağım Yar
okadar ufak ki ya ne yapacağım ben
havzasının havalarıyla Ben fazlalığım
havası Yani buradan Hani çok büyük bir
hedeflere ulaşma çok büyük markalarla
çalışmak gerçekten çok uzak gibi
görünüyor Yani ben de babamın şey
demiştim soğuk rol model aldım bir kadın
vardı ama çok gerçekten çok güzel şöyle
diyor ya bir ürün İkisinden birisini
falan Babam her şey demişti Hayal
dünyasında yaşıyorsun falan Ben de o gün
babam bunu yani hani dikkate almadım
değil ama yani niye olmasın ki diye
kendime çevirmiş Team Çünkü benim annem
öğretmen öğretmen ve Ali'nin çok iyi
yani ayın 15'inde maaş aldığını ve o
maaşla birlikte bu tip Hayat yaşadık Ama
bunlar bana böyle artık sıradan Ben
başka bir şey yapmalıyız diye düştü
sürekli uyanan bir şey olarak geri
dönüyorum adına babamın doğru bana
dediği şeyi ne hayatım bunu sunduğu
A101 cümle artık hayatımda ilk edecek
bir şey ama ben orada babamın bana
söylediğini yani bir kulağından girip
bir kulağından çıkmadı da Evet baba
Doğru diyorsun hayatım yat Olabilir ama
ben Yolumda Gitmeye devam edeceğim dedim
ve yine aynı şeyleri yapmaya kalmamış
sorular çekmeye tarafta bildiğine devam
ettim burada bir söz var Eğer bir insan
birini süsler sana mesaj atıyorum
hayatında size eşlik eden insanlar olur
yani benim Senin yüzünden ben onu yaptım
senin anlaşma yaptım diyecek olursanız
birisini şarj ettiğinizde bile sizin
şarj parmağını tuşladınız bir şey
göstereceğim altında dövüş parmağında
sizi gösteriyor yani hayatının susayıp
Sen var sizi zorlayabilir Size Gülşah
para sunabilir ama Onları göstereceğim
de geliş parmağını sizi gösteriyor yani
olay gelir size bitiyor eğer ben onlara
devam onları takıp o yollar geri
dönseydim ve ve Hayallerinden gitgide
uzak Evet şu anda fabrikada olmayacaktım
şu an Vücudunuzun olacaktır şu an bir
marka kurucusu olmayacaktım Ben hiç
kimseye dikkate almadan hiçbir şekilde
onları çok fazla Sen bana onları
kulağıma takıp yani ona dedikleri
şeyleri dinleyip dikkate alıp ama yine
de yolda yürümeye devam ettim yani
hayatın size sunduğu dışarıdan Siz
etkileyecek bir şeyler yapılacak ama
size de size Tamam kullanmalısınız yoksa
hayalinize giden o yollar sizi çok fazla
düşürüp kaldıracaktır ama Düşünsenize
kalması hepbilirim
güzel diyeceğim şeyi Bence
şimdi sonrasında ise şimdi bu da çok bir
şey ama bir yola çıktığınızda hepside
başkalarını Kötü etkilenmeyecek veya
hayat şartları sizi kötü etkileyecek Siz
de bu yolda hataları yapacaksınız yani
yolda yürürken daima her attığımız adım
sizlere götürmeyecek sizi gelir getiren
birçok adım atacaksınız ve ben en iyi
olan sizi en çok güzel lütfen şeyler de
bulunan yine yatırılan bir kızıp
anlatacağım
kullanırım artık anne buna sözü tanımı
oluşmuş az çok yani 61 takipçi var
zamanlar yine 61 takipçin var ama
etrafta ve bunun sırt alımı yaşayan
Toprak zaman zamanlarda
2016-2017 yılında
sonra da ben böyle çok telaşı bir hayatı
vardı İstanbul taşıma dönemlerinde falan
kendi böyle çok fotoğraf çekti vakit
bulamıyorum Çok fazla patlayan tarifim
var acaba toparlayayım da var o
zamanlara göre bazı 34 sahne yani fazla
yan tarafları var Sürekli onları
paylaşmak fotoğraf şekilde fırsatım
olmadığı için fotoğraflar Pis desten
gibi fotoğrafları bulup onları
paylaşacağım falan Sonra bizim sektörde
Böyle herkesin mutluluğunu ister insan
çok yok ve ben daima Instagram'a
girdiğinde hep şeyleri Herkes beni
seviyor çok mutluyum hep böyle bir
mantıkla yaşadığımız para hatırlıyorum
yani ve sonrasında Ben of İnternetten
aldım fotoğrafları benim seni Öyleyse
hemen insanlar buluyor Ve işte hırsız
hırsız Evet Hırsızı kendi tarifi değil
şu an ve bana hiç yağmurları geliyor Ben
sosyal medyada bilmiyorum ertesi gün
derde 12-15 takipçi video ben bu olay
Yani nasıl olabilir Tamam diye
düşünüyorum Yani aslında ben o
fotoğraflarını paylaşırken sanki onunla
bakayım Bugün ne getireceğini hali
farkından Yani hiçbir şey yapıyorsun bu
hata ama olan başka çarem yok olan
tarihleri asla başladı fotoğraflarını
paylaşıyorum böyle böyle oh aradan sonra
ben nasıl bunu pozitif bir etki
geçirmeliyim diye Kafam koymaya başladım
aslında burada istediğim şu Siz hata
yapsanız bile sizin yaptığınız hata
olduğunda sizi bir noktada yere
götürebilir Siz o yaptığımız hatanın
sonucuna olanı tamamen kendinizi bile
çekmek ezme Aslında o yaptığımız hatanın
sizi ne kadar Daha fazla Ne söyleyeceğim
davranırsanız hayatını daha fazla
çözümler bulabilirsiniz ben ne yaptım da
ki atıyorum kalktım güçlü takipçim
gitmiş ekşi sözlük'te hala yazılar var
insanlar birileri negatif yorumlar
yapıyor süre İşte o hırsızlık Duydunuz
mu falan inanılmaz derecede seni
çağırırım ben olmayabilirim tarifler bir
fotoğrafını sadece almış Evet bu bir
hata Bunun için özür dileriz
takipçilerine o zaman sonra ben kalktım
O zaman ben çok YouTube şey videolar
yolla yoksa videolarda tarifler Yok
kalktım videolar çekerek tarifleri
paylaşmaya devam ettim ve inanın o giden
12000 takipçi kat kat her bana geldi
sonrasında inanılmaz derecede artık
değil mi dünya bir hesabım oldu Eğer ben
bana yapılan oldu şahına kapılıp
Gerçekten bu yolda yani pislik dönseydim
aslında hiçbir şekilde hesabı büyüyecek
ve bende bu işi bırakıp gidip tekrardan
her sonra çalışmaya devam edecektim asla
Her işte böyle zorluklar var Yani
yapmamız gereken şırdan hayatım Bu
belgeler olunca veya kendi hata
yaptığınızda Gerçekten diyorum bak ya
salata ve cebimize koyup bir şekilde
onları çözüm edip yolumuza devam etmek
biliyordu bu olayları yaşarken çok zor
olabiliyor ama gerçekten hatalar bile
bir şekilde deneyimle dövüş tüm de geldi
de inanılmaz güzel şeyler bizi bekliyor
O yüzden bugün kişi sayım demek istedim
Yani yapacağınız hataları küçük sayılır
Hayal kurduğunuz ne varsa onlar
ulaşılmaz bir onları küçükse Çünkü
ulaşılabilir kalın demek istiyorum
aslında tam hayalini kurduk
pişireceğiz yani her şeyini Herşey ya Of
İşte onu çok kolay falan böyle bu moda
takılacağız Hayır tabii ki küçük
zararımız gereken ve çok mavi çok güzel
şeyler var onlardan da bahsedeceğim
küçümseme dediğimiz Neyse benim
hayatımda çok fazla uyarlama dın bir şey
kendini işim sevmem kendimi kişi
söylediğinizde insanlar genelde bu Bu
nasıl bir kendine kendine içindeki
davranışlarımıza ben bunu buraya yani
şuan Bulunduğum yerde daima Aldım kendi
bir Şimdi eve geldim bunu da ilk defa
vurun paylaşıyorum ben bir şey
başlayacağım tam daima en iyisini
başardığım için sürekli Ya bunu yaptım
ama ya şu daha yapabilirdim böyle böyle
böyle sürekli yere gidiyorum ama bugün
noktada Bunu bana veren bir şey olduğu
için burada size mi anlatmak istedim
yani çünkü bir insan çok fazla bol
olmamalı çok önemli zaten abla Kendinizi
çok iyi oldu bir insan gibi asla Hani
göstermeye olabilir tam olmayın ama
kendinize Değer verin ben hesabımı kollu
Biraz kendini hor davranıyor Çünkü
yaptığım her şey çok başarılı bile olsa
hava şarkısı yapmak için bitip daha önce
gitmem lazım biraz daha ya bu yapılır
zaten bunu daha yapmam lazım Böyle böyle
Şu an buradayım Ama bence bir noktada
insanın gerçekten kendi yapabildiklerini
farkına vardı kendine değer verip
sonraki adıma önce etme ve
kendinizi Ah hapşu Sevmeyin
hayallerinizi küçük sayının Çünkü
Hayaller ulaşılabilir ama kendinizi
kişisel vereceksiniz O hayal gerçek
kılabilirsiniz onları istiyorum şimdi
olarak etrafınızdaki insanları asla
küçümsemeyin Aynen özellikler işte anne
baba değer verilmez işte Yağmur olacağız
evler karıştırılır karıştırılır ya da
bir Etrafındaki insanlar size değişik
yosunları onlara vermezsiniz falan ama
demek istediğim şu etrafımızdaki
insanların görüşleri çok fazla değer
verin Çünkü herkesin hayatı başarısız
çok farklı bu Karşıdan gelen bir insan
da olabilir hayatınız dayanıklı olan
arkadaşımız olabilir yani tamamen
sizinle yolu kesişmiş herhangi bir insan
da olabilir Ben özellikle burda ekibi
örnek göstermek istiyorum şimdi benim
edildiğinde sekiz kişiyi ben bunu tek
başıma çıkmışım ama 8 kişilik bir ekibin
ve ekibime giren her arkadaşıma sularım
senin ağzına o herkes veren inanılmaz
larla Çünkü ben burada tek başıma
değilim Ben hayatta böyle bakabilirim
ama sizin devam hayatı böyle bakayım
dilimizin fazla elleri farklı İmam
hatipleri var ve hepimiz birbirimize
İnanmaz karşılar katabiliriz Ben herkesi
çok değer verip gerçekten onlarla
birlikte yoluna bakmayı çok seviyorum
Yine çok sevdim Amerikalı videolarını
bir söz var insan hayatında en çok
görüştüm 5 insan ortalamasıdır diye
söylemiş Ve gerçekten ya bence çok doğru
Eğer siz hayatınızdaki insanların doğru
seçer ve hayatınıza bir noktada yön
vermesine katkıda bulunursanız onların
kişisel atarsanız sizi bir orada çok
fazla veriyor geçer İnsanlar olacaktır
diye düşünüyorum o yüzden onları da bir
şey tanıyoruz
bu ve biyolojik Temmuz'da kahve tek var
zaten yani ister bir sınıfı çektim oğlum
isterseniz başka bir işi yapmak
isterseniz ilk unsur oğlum daha metre
kaybetme Ben her şeyleri yapan bir çok
insan var Ve şimdi bu yola girdiğinizde
rekabete yenildim at yarışı çözmekte çok
tehlikeli benim size tavsiyem sarı
kahvemizi şöyle kullanım yani insanların
ne yaptığını ne şekilde yaradığını
davran farkında olur ama bunu asla bir
ya çevirmeye Çünkü yarışa çevirdiğinizde
Siz zaten kendi yolunuzdan bakıyorsunuz
ve aslına hiç farkında olmadan yarıştığı
nız insanlarla birlikte başbaşa takip
koşturmalı bir olayı oluşturuyoruz hemen
Bu çok tehlikeli o zaman kendi yolumuzu
unutuyorsunuz kendi varmak istediğiniz
hayalimizde uzaklaşır sunuz Çünkü ben de
herkes kendi başına çok Özgün Yani kendi
değerleri kendi yargıları inanılmaz
derecede bir enerji harcıyorsunuz ve Ben
seninle orayı Tabi tarzımıza gerçekten
yürüdüğümüz olan çok güzel
anlaşıyorsunuz benim bu sayılar yaptığın
her şeyde bu neden İstanbul'da yaşadığı
mesela Çünkü İslamın
uluslar yaşanılan Adana'da yaşıyorum
seni adam ayrıldı hiçbir bu oluyor yani
şu an ona bir şirketim var ama yani
özgür olmak ve gerçekten yaratıcı şeyler
adresine kaç başkalarına bağlı değil ben
o etkinliklere gitmek ya orada gerçekten
çok farklı fikirlerle insanların
tamirini zehirlemek bana iyi gelmiyor
ben daha ama yaratıcı olayında Gerçekten
beni seven ama saygı duyan insanlarla
belki oğlum kafası dayım ve bunlardan
şifalı hepsinde zaten çok çok seviyorum
beni seven çok iyi tamam onları orası
yılı gönderiyorum herkesin severek diye
birşey yok Dediğim gibi ben bir
başlarken daima herkesin sevdiği
düşünsem de şu an çok farklı bir gün
sonra karşınızdayım Herkese saygı
duyuyorum herkesin farklı yürüyorlar
daha o dönem Yollar düğmeler açıklarının
rekabetin farkında olur ama asla kendi
unutmayın kendi yolundan yürümeye size
daima iyi gelecektir Şu an buradayım
soğan bir marka kurucusuyum güçlü kadın
güçlerini projesi sahibinde Bu proje ile
birlikte kadın girişinize destekliyoruz
ve şuan web sitemizde 25-30 tane kadın
girişimi'nin ürünlerini satıyoruz da bu
yola çıkarken sadece Kendim bir şeyler
yapacağım diye aslaa çıkmadım kendime
olan saygımı Belki de azaltan başarılı
olmazdım Çünkü gerçekten bizim tekrar
çok acımasız ve çok basit görünüyor yani
işte bir şey paylaşıyor işte ya bu kadar
falan öyle bir şey değil ben gerçekten
birşeyler öğretmek istiyorum herkesin
hayatına dokunmak istiyorum ve her zaman
diyorum Burada diyeceğim Benim en büyük
amaçlarından birisi herkesin bu hayattan
zevk alması ve herkesin düzgün gerçekten
heyecan Duygu bir şey ya Hızlı benim en
çok önemli şeyler de tane bu kendiniz
orantıyı yaptığınız işi önem Sayın
işimiz zaten iş için olmasın yani onun
için heyecanımız için o işlemi istiyorum
ben sessiz manzara unutmayın verilmediği
için teşekkür ederim Kendine çok iyi bak
[Müzik]
[Alkış]